foreign
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar verification of Auto antibody
serology tests practical considerations
for The Clinical Laboratory I'm Susie
Valdez of La roots and I will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots and brought to you by biorad to
learn more visit them at biohyphen
rad.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during this presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Dr
Melissa Snyder the co-director and the
antibody Immunology laboratory at the
Mayo Clinic
Melissa welcome you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone my name is Melissa Snyder
and I'm an associate professor of
laboratory medicine and pathology at the
Mayo Clinic in Rochester Minnesota I'm
so glad you were able to join me today
for this webinar on verification of
autoantibody serology tests practical
considerations for The Clinical
Laboratory
I only have one disclosure to make and
that is that I have been a member of the
Strategic advisory committee for werfin
the learning objectives for this
presentation are one to be able to
recognize inherit heterogeneity of
autoantibodies and the impact and the
impact this has on clinical testing
we're going to be able to describe the
regulatory parameters that are needed
for verification of FDA cleared and
laboratory developed tests
we're going to look at specific
approaches on how you might verify these
different parameters specifically for
auto antibody assays and lastly we'll
talk a little bit about the drawbacks of
using method comparison to assess
accuracy for autoantibody serology
testing
so as a way of introduction for my
presentation today I really want to be
clear what we're talking about and the
essays that we're going to be focusing
on today are ones where we detect an
antibody that has specific reactivity
against an antigen now in the context of
autoimmune disease we'd be talking about
a self antigen but these antigen
specific antibodies may also be detected
against microorganisms in the context of
infectious disease or against
environmental antigens in the context of
Allergic Disease
now if we're going to be really focusing
on autoimmune diseases today and what
the role of serology testing is and it's
important to point out that this is
applicable to both systemic and organ
specific diseases and if we think about
the role of serology testing in these
various types of diseases we see that we
have one application which is diagnostic
however it is important to note that
these diagnostic application Auto
antibodies generally are not considered
diagnostic markers in and of themselves
so we don't use them in isolation but
interpret the results in the context of
other pieces of information both
laboratory and clinical
there are a small subset of Auto
antibody tests which are useful for
monitoring although it really is limited
to only specific diseases and specific
Auto antibody reactivities
I think it's also important that we take
a look at the different methods that are
used for determination or identification
of Auto antibodies assays
the basis of autoantibody serology tests
really are to use a capture antigen
which will allow you to separate the
specific Auto antibody that you're
looking for from other immunoglobulins
that are present within the patient's
sample
you can classify these assays as being
either immune complex based which is
based on visualization of a complex that
forms between the antigen and the auto
antibody and I would consider this
really a direct detection of an antibody
antigen interaction
this is a compared to immunoassay
methods which are really based on
detection of the auto antibody binding
to an antigen where you have a secondary
label detection antibody and this I
think of as more of an indirect method
of detecting the antibody antigen
interactive interaction because you're
requiring the use of a secondary or
detection antibody
looking a little bit more in detail at
immune complex based methods you have
gel face methods which um where you have
formation of the immune complex in a
solid phase such as single or double
immunodefusion and then you have more of
the solution phase methods where you
have formation of the immune complex and
solutions such as you find with
immunoprecipitation assays nephilimetric
or turbidometric assays
and then if we look at the immunoassays
we have in direct Amino fluorescence as
being one subclassification we have line
or dot blood assays we have solid phase
immunoassays which there are many
variations of such as enzyme amino acids
can be luminescence or fluoroenzyme
immunoassays and then we have the
multiplex immunoassays as well which is
kind of a a subclass of solid phase
assays to a certain a certain way of
thinking but we separate them out here
because they are Multiplex as opposed to
more the traditional solid phase amino
acids
the other thing I'd like to touch on
before we start talking about
verification requirements is the
characteristics of autoantibodies and
one particular characteristic I think we
really need to appreciate is the fact
that auto antibodies unlike most other
protein analytes are heterogeneous in
and of themselves and this is true in
terms of their epitome specificity of
their isotype class as well as the
differences in Affinity or avidity the
antibody might have for this particular
Target antigen
the other thing we need to remember is
that when we are looking or we're
talking about detecting an auto antibody
we're really talking about assessing for
the repertoire of Auto antibodies that a
patient might have this is not a single
Auto antibody but rather a collection of
autoantibodies
and this repertoire of Auto antibodies
or this collection May differ from
Patient to Patient but it may even
differ within a single patient over time
the key takeaway here though that we
need to appreciate is that autoantibody
heterogeneous heterogeneity does have a
very significant impact on both the
analytical performance of the method as
well as its diagnostic characteristics
so let's just we'll really be focusing
primarily on immunoassays today so I
thought it would be relevant to just
think a little bit about the components
of an immunoassay so we have an antigen
which really makes sure that this is
what's capturing your autoantibody we
really want to make sure that this is
representative of the Native antigen
this could be purified or recombinant
but somehow it needs to represent
whatever native antigen the autoantibody
is recognizing
we need to have some source of
calibrator or control material and the
source of this material can be very
important
um
whether it's sourced directly from
patient samples or whether it's patient
material that comes from some sort of
some kind of commercial source
the calibration scheme is also something
that is very relevant for the
performance of an of a method this could
be a calibration scheme that is
established for each assay such as you
have in the solid phase like an enzyme
immunoassay or it could be lot specific
from a manufacturer such as you might
find on some of the more automated
platforms
and then we have the detection system
we can think of a detection system into
components we have the isotype
specificity whether it's only detecting
IGG IGM IGA or perhaps a combination of
various isotypes and then we have the
label that is found on the detection
antibody and I think this is primarily
relevant for the analytical measuring
range and the methods of detection that
we commonly see are colorimetric
luminescent and fluorescent
the other thing I want to touch on
idea to touch on before we get into
verification requirements is this idea
of quantitation
so if we look at assays that are
qualitative these are assays where we
report a result as positive or negative
and this is this identification of
positive or negative is usually in
relation to some sort of cutoff value
now we're going to differentiate
differentiate that from quantitative
methods where you report a concentration
in an absolute absolute unit such as
milligram per liter something along
those lines
these quantitative methods are generally
traceable to some sort of certified
reference material or CRM or some
possibly some reference method
in between qualitative and quantitative
we have our semi-quantitative assays and
how do semi-quantitative assays differ
between qualitative versus quantitative
well with some of quantitative assays
usually these are going to be reported
in some kind of relative concentration
such as units per milliliter or perhaps
even a tighter
in addition semi-quantitative assays
generally are not traceable to a
certified reference material or to a
reference method and when we think about
autoantibody testing generally we're
thinking about semi-quantitative assays
however I would like us to kind of think
more Beyond just that we are measuring
concentration but really think that we
what we're really measuring is
reactivity and not exactly not
necessarily a concentration and to keep
in mind that the result that was
reported does not necessarily equate to
a true concentration because there are
so many other parameters that impact the
reactivity that you might detect in an
assay such as the Affinity of the
antibody for that particular antigen and
not just solely related to how much
antibody is present within a patient
sample
foreign
so we need to think about regulatory
classifications and when we think about
this for for
um for laboratory tests many of you I'm
sure are very familiar with this we have
FDA cleared where the FDA has reviewed
data for a test and approves that it be
used as an in vitro Diagnostic and
usually when asked when Laboratories are
performing FDA cleared assays they are
using the manufacturer's instructions
now laboratory May modify an FDA cleared
assay they've made some sort of change
in how they perform the testing they've
deviated from the manufacture
manufacturer's instructions and these
would be considered FDA modified tests
and then we have the laboratory develop
test where the Clinical Laboratory
itself develops and validates the method
for the purposes of testing patient
samples
so what are the regulatory verification
requirements and that we have to follow
between these different types of assays
for FDA cleared we have the four primary
parameters of precision reportable range
or analytical measuring range or AMR the
reference range and accuracy
for FDA modified or ldts we still have
to fulfill those four primary
requirements but in addition there's
analytical sensitivity analytical
specificity and then CLIA also
highlights that any other
characteristics that are required for
test performance may need to be assessed
as part of the verification for an FDA
modified or ldt
for the purposes of the presentation
today just in the time limits that we
have I'm only going to be focusing on
the four requirements
needed for FDA cleared which is the
Precision reportable range reference
range and accuracy
so let's start off with precision
Precision is the closest close defined
as the closeness of agreement between
independent replicate measurements and
this may include assessments of
intra-assay or within run precision and
inter-assay or between run precision and
usually the data is expressed as a
percent CV
the experimental approach is usually
pretty standard usually we see replicate
measurements of about of 20 is usually
considered appropriate and this is true
for within run and between run and you
like usually we like to assess Precision
across the analytical measuring range of
the of the assay
so here's some example data that I
generated in my laboratory this is for
anti-saccharomyces service CI IGG
antibodies you can see that we've
selected three samples uh different
reactivities which are shown here the
mean that reactivities shown here in
this first row for the two samples what
we're showing here is intra assay
precision and here's the inter-assay
Precision you can see our standard
deviation and then calculating a percent
CV for each of those samples
here's another example of some data from
anticardial lip and IGM testing this the
data the tables are set up in the same
way we looked at three samples again
across the analytical measuring range
and then showing the percent CV as our
final calculation for both intra assay
and inter-assay precision
and I would say for auto antibody
testing that the Precision is one of the
more straightforward verification
requirements that we can that we can
assess for however I think there are
still some important points to consider
for precision when you're thinking about
autoantibody assay testing
the first is the sample source that you
use
we generally try to use patient samples
or patient pools I think this provides a
more real world evaluation particularly
because we're using that patient Matrix
but in addition it represents all
aspects of the testing protocol
including the dilution of the patient
sample that might be needed prior to
performing the assay
sometimes QC material can be used and
sometimes we do include it in our
Precision experiments usually as an
addition to our our patient samples and
it can be useful as a comparison to give
you a sense of how the QC material will
perform in terms of precision and
as you begin to offer the testing
clinically sometimes you will take QC or
even calibrator material and Spike it
into a negative serum to make it more of
a patient Matrix but again it just
depends on the availability of that
material
as well as the availability of your
patient samples
that we do is say that usually we assess
Precision across the analytical
measuring range and I have kind of two
um you know thoughts about this
particular kind of aspect of assessing
for precision one is I always ask this
question of myself but really what is
the value of assessing Precision in a
negative sample because really I think
what you're doing here is measuring the
background does it give you a sense of
what the Precision is in that area it
does but again it's more background and
not necessarily measuring Precision of a
low sample and it may be more valuable
to try to assess Precision close to the
cutoff of your of your method rather
than trying to just use a negative
sample
but I will say it is something that we
do routinely it's just something I
always wonder whether it's something
that we should be doing or whether it's
something that is needed
the other issue is that we always also
try to assess Precision at the high end
or the higher end of our analytical
measuring range but the playing fact is
that sometimes samples with high
reactivity may not be available and it
may be challenging to find samples where
you could really assess
um across the AMR for precision
so next step brings us out to a portable
range I'd like to cover this aspect of
verification next so reportable range is
also known as the analytical measuring
range or AMR
this is the range of analyte
concentrations over which specified
criteria are met such as precision and
bias
now usually the AMR spans concentrations
from the lower limit of quantitation to
the upper limit of quantitation and this
is generally limited to the linear range
of the assay meaning that when you
dilute a patient sample that you see a
decrease in the
concentration that you calculate
with the appropriate dilution
so this can be done in two different
ways for auto antibody testing at least
for we could do mixing studies where we
take a high and a low sample when we
combine them in vary ratios to measure
um to assess for linearity and we could
do a dilution evaluation where you do
serial dilutions of a high patient
sample what I'd like to do is show you
some data from some actual verifications
that we've performed in my laboratory
showing these different approaches and
how they may differ and how the
different types of data that you might
uh that you might see
so first we I'll show you some
reportable range data from tissue
transglutaminase IGA antibody testing
and these were dilution studies that we
performed using High patient samples and
we started with two different patient
samples one at a 35.7 results and one at
an 84.2 and then we did two-fold cereal
dilutions which are shown kind of down
the column here we measured those
results after performing the dilutions
and then we compared that to what we
would expect for those samples based on
the dilution that was performed
and we did that again for these two
samples and in in order to keep the
table try to keep it a little cleaner
I'm not actually showing you the
calculation of the percent recovery here
but what you can certainly see I think
is that as the dilution increase as we
continue down with the serial dilutions
the difference between the measured and
expected value on a percent basis
becomes larger and larger and that is
true for both samples as we compare the
measured result to the expected result
here for sample two we can see these
measured results compared to what we
would have expected they always tended
to be higher as well they tended to
again increase in the percent difference
between them as it as we increase with
the dilutions
and so that's really what we saw
whenever we did the solution experiment
is that even though when we diluted the
sample we certainly saw a decrease in
the measured reactivity that we were
detecting however that however this
recovery was not linear in comparison to
what we would have expected those
concentrations to be based on the
starting reactivity of the sample
now we took a different approach with
beta2 glycoprotein one IGA antibodies we
did a mixing study in this context and
we looked at we found a high patient and
a low patient sample and then mixed them
in varying ratios and here's what I'll
show you here again I'm only I'm only
showing you data on one sample here we
took a high sample with a reactivity of
about 130 units we had a low sample with
the reactivity of 22 units and then we
measured we combined them in different
ratios measured the concentration or
sorry measured the reactivity that we
observed and then compared that to what
the expected reactivity would be based
on the ratio between the high needs and
the low neat sample
and again for the to try to be more
simplified in the data I'm showing you
I'm not I didn't calculate any percent
recoveries or percent differences here
however I think you can appreciate the
fact that what we're seeing on these
measured values is very close to what we
would see expected based on the
theoretical mixing of this High sample
and the low sample and in fact all of
our percent differences here between
these two values were within plus minus
five percent so certainly within what we
would have expected
another set of data I'd like to show you
is proteinase III and anti-milo
peroxidase IGG antibodies and on this
particular data set I'm showing you some
dilution studies then I'm going to show
you data for both proteinase 3 and Milo
peroxidase on a couple of different
samples for each I want to show you the
differences that we saw here so let's
look at pr3 to start with so for pr3 we
started with a neat sample and then did
serial dilutions and one to four or one
to ten and one to a hundred and then we
calculated the reactivity based on that
dilution to compare to the needs and you
can see for pr3 that for this first
sample when we did the one to four and
the one to ten that we got very
um close to the value we would have
expected based on the neat sample taking
into account these Solutions when we got
to the one to a hundred the signal was
below the AMR so we couldn't calculate
it
on the same we saw the same thing with
the second sample where we started with
a grade of an eight value at a one to
four it was still a greater than which
would have calculated at a greater than
32 however when we got to the 1 to 10
and 1 to 100 we calculated very similar
numeric values in our in our unit
um unitary activities
in comparison when we looked at the
myeloperoxidase we had one sample here
where we started at a 6.3 at the neat
but you can see as we did the one to
four one to ten and one to a hundred we
had dramatically increasing
reactivities that we were detecting when
we took into account the dilution this
was not true for every myeloperoxidase
antibody that we we saw because here we
have a sample with a greater than eight
value on the neat sample when we did the
one to four one to ten and one to a
hundred we saw very consistent results
across those Solutions
so our take home from this is that the
dilution responses may actually differ
between patients and or may actually
differ between the antigen specificities
so what can I say about reportable range
and how you verify that for auto
antibody testing well first of all I
think it's fair to say that when you do
dilution or mixing studies you should
demonstrate a decrease in reactivity
although oftentimes it's not linear
sometimes it is as we saw with the beta2
glycoprotein the IGA testing with the
mixing studies that we had very very
good comparison between the measured and
expected but it's not always the case
what choice you use for the sample
dilution what Matrix you use is often a
difficult
it's often difficult to know this
sometimes we use a negative serum
sometimes we use dilute sometimes we use
both it just it really I think depends
on the on the assay that you're looking
at the method
um whether you have some negative serum
that's available that that might
actually be a more more appropriate but
I think it's sometimes worthwhile is is
that you may have to try both
foreign
just like just as with Precision
sometimes you are limited on the
availability of the high sample and so
assessing linearity over the entire
analytical measuring range may be
difficult there are recommendations that
when you're assessing for linearity that
the sample that you use should be within
a certain percentage I think about 15 of
the upper limit of quantitation but
again there there may not be you may not
always have
um access to a sample like that and so
you may be limited to assessing for
linearity just based on whatever samples
that you have at your disposal
but I think lastly I would say that
sometimes you just need several
approaches to really assess the
analytical measuring range you may need
to do mixing studies you may need to
also do dilution studies and I think
it's often I think very important that
you correlate this with your Precision
data because again the analytical
measuring range really does tie to this
idea that this is the range over which
you are able to verify certain criteria
of an analytical method and that would
be specifically Precision so correlating
what you see on your linearity
experiments with what you see with
Precision for the autoantibody testing I
think can provide valuable information
when you're establishing the analytical
measuring range for your for your assay
now let's move into reference range so
reference range or reference interval
another terminology is the range of
analyte concentrations that you would
observe in healthy individuals so
generally speaking we would measure the
analyte concentration in a cohort of
healthy or non-disease control
individuals and then establish a central
or one-sided 95th percentile
so the experimental approach if you're
verifying a reference range that might
have been established by a manufacturer
generally using healthy controls uh 20
individuals per category and I put that
per category in there because if you
want to also establish a range in adults
and Pediatrics you would need 20 in each
of those categories if you think there
would be differences between males and
females 20 per category would be
important would be needed as well
if you're talking about establishing a
reference range
um usually 120 is considered a robust
establishment a robust number for
establishing a reference range and again
that would be per category so adults
versus Pediatrics males versus females
Etc
so let me show you
um let me just come back to this so this
is something that we do very frequently
when we are looking at Auto antibody
testing and I'll just show you some data
that we've generated from some reference
range verifications
in our laboratory for a couple of
different autoantibody assays the first
time we'll start with is anti-ccp so
when we did our CCP IGG verification we
started with 95 healthy controls we
looked at the reference range that was
suggested by the manufacturer which is
greater than or equal to 20 units as
being positive and when we did our
reference range verification and we
measured our healthy controls we found
that basically all of our tests all of
our results were less than 15.6 in other
words below the analytical measuring
range for the assay so technically we
verified this reference range because
all of our healthy controls were less
than the fell within the negative range
for this particular method
our data for TTG we took a similar
approach although because again we were
verifying a manufacturer's range we
started with 20 adult healthy controls
the reference range for this particular
assay was four to ten units per
milliliter being weak positive and then
greater than 10 being positive when we
measured the 20 healthy controls that we
had we had a reference range our
reference range verification showed that
19 of our samples were undetectable or
falling below the analytical measuring
range at less than 1.2 units per
milliliter we had one sample that gave
us a numeric value but it was still less
than the cutoff for week positive so
again all 20 of the samples that we
measured were have been classified as
negative
according to the manufacturer's range
lastly I want to show you data from
anti-phosphatidylserine prothromb and
IGG testing so in this case we had a
healthy control cohort of 120
individuals and we had a reference range
from the manufacturer of greater than 30
units being positive
when we conducted our reference range
verification we had the my a small
number of samples we're showing as
undetectable or less than 9.4 below the
AMR for the assay
the majority of the samples that we had
were giving a numeric value however they
were still would have still been
classified as negative or being less
than 30 under the category for the the
manufacturer had set for negative
however we did find that we had a
significant number 13 of our samples
actually were above the cutoff of 30
that was established by the manufacturer
so in this case because we had you know
we had our full 120 samples we actually
established a new reference range for
when we went when we implemented our
assay we kept the 30 cut off as being
negative we established a borderline
range and this was based on the
reactivity or the unit values that were
we were seeing in the cohort of healthy
controls where the results were showing
above 30.
so we established from 30.1 to 40 as a
borderline range and then anything at
40.1 and above would then be considered
positive
so
what else can we say about reference
range when we're establishing or
verifying a reference range for auto
antibody testing I think there is value
in demonstrating that individuals
without disease of Interest are negative
for the auto antibody reactivity
however I I think that what we have to
keep in mind is that this does tend to
mise it does tend to maximize the
sensitivity of the testing and may
actually give us a somewhat lower
specificity because the healthy controls
that we see often are below the
analytical measuring range of the assay
that said as the example I showed you
with phosphatidylserine prothrombin I
think there still is value in doing this
because sometimes we do find methods
where our healthy controls actually do
tell us that the the
um the cutoff that has been established
may not be completely appropriate for
our testing population
there are other ways to do this and this
often can be very challenging however
but we we can
um
move to the direction of establishing a
cutoff which allows us to distinguish a
negative from positive result this
usually requires that we have not only a
healthy control population but also a
population of individuals with a disease
of Interest this allows us to identify a
cut off or a point where we can have
optimal distinction between healthy and
the disease population in other words
we're establishing a cut off based on
both healthy and disease population
rather than the healthy population alone
and I think this really allows us to
evaluate both sensitivity and
specificity of the testing but this does
provide this does have a lot of
challenges to it because you know we may
not always have access to a population
of individuals who have the disease of
Interest
lastly now I'd like to move into
accuracy assessment and how we might
assess for accuracy for auto antibody
testing so again let's think about what
do we mean by accuracy accuracy can be
defined as the closest closeness of
agreement between a measured value and
the true concentration of the analyte
well based on that definition I guess I
would ask can we really assess accuracy
for autoantibody testing
and I think I would have to say no
because we really don't know the true
concentration of the analyte or the
autoantibody that we're looking at
because we don't have certified
reference materials we don't really have
traceability to a gold standard or or
certified reference methodology
so if we can't assess trueness if we
can't assess the true concentration of
our analyte how do we evaluate accuracy
for auto antibody assays and in large
part I would say we're really not
assessing for accuracy when we do these
experiments however there are some
things that we can do that will give us
I think a good handle or at least some
understanding of the performance of our
Auto antibody testing
the classic method that people use is to
do a method comparison which is
um which can be useful and we'll talk a
little bit about that in a moment
we may be able to correlate
um one particular Auto antibody with a
related autoantibody
or we may be able to correlate with
clinical diagnosis
and again I'd like to show you some
example data from accuracy assessments
that we've that we've conducted in my
laboratory for verification of
autoantibody testing and kind of
illustrate some of these different
points so the first one I'll talk about
is the anti-ccp IGG testing
uh this is a marker for rheumatoid
arthritis and when we began doing this
testing we started off by just doing a
simple method comparison between two
enzyme immunoassay methods we collected
a sample cohort of 275 patients
individuals I should say we had a total
of 85 positive specimens based on the
predicate enzyme amino acid that we were
comparing to at 190 negative samples and
this is the correlation that we saw
across those 275 samples
so our results showed that overall we
had a concordance of 94.9 percent
between these two different enzyme amino
acids which I think is very good from a
qualitative concordance perspective
but we did have these 14 discrepant
results and they're shown here we had 11
which were positive on assay number one
and negative on our predicate and three
samples which were positive on the
predicate and negative on our uh the
essay we were evaluating
and so we began to investigate what the
nature of these discrepancies would be
now
I'm going to show you two different
examples of these discrepancies and
start to think about how we might again
investigate these discrepancies so here
are two different examples sample number
one and and I I should say to you that
the cutoff for essay number one is less
than five so anything less than five is
considered negative for essay number two
a cut off of less than 20. so anything
below 20 is considered negative
so this first sample we see
you know on the first assay is giving a
less than value so it's considered to be
negative on essay number two it's giving
a result that's a I would say a
borderline positive just above the
cutoff
I would say this is a discrepancy that I
would classify as kind of being close to
the cutoff is the result is the reason
you're seeing the discrepancy I think
sometimes these types of discrepancies
may be reflecting differences in the
calibration or how the cutoff was
established between the two methods
and
I think what's relevant to point out
here is that if you adjust the cutoff of
the of one or the other assays you can
start to improve the correlation between
the two methods now that's not to say
that you you should adjust the cutoff
it's just to say that if you adjust the
cutoff you might start to improve your
correlation
now that is the different from the
sample number two that I'm showing you
here on Sample number two we get a a
negative or undetectable result on the
on the first method but a significantly
positive result on the second method and
these are what I would say are more
substantial or significant discrepancies
now there are we can talk about why we
see these discrepancies we'll get into
that in a little bit a little bit in
just a minute
sometimes I think these discrepancies
are reflecting differences in the
antigen between the methods or at least
maybe it's more important maybe it's
more accurate to say it's how the auto
antibody is recognizing the antigen
between the difference between the
methods maybe explaining some of this
discrepancy
also relevant to point out that if you
try to adjust the cutoff it's probably
not going to help you improve the
correlation because you have such a such
a significant discrepancy between the
two methods but you're left asking
yourself when you have discrepancies
like this which is the quote correct
result are you seeing this as a true
positive and this is a false negative or
vice versa is the sample truly negative
and what you're seeing here is a false
positive
now I think though
we should probably stop in our
discussion of how we assess for accuracy
and really think about what do we mean
by the by a false positive or too
positive when we think about
autoantibody testing in particular
so false positive result generally is a
test result which interaccurately
identifies the presence of a condition
or a disease
but with autoantibody testing maybe we
need to think about this a little bit
differently in the sense that I think
you can have an analytical false
positive which is different from a
clinical false positive
so what do I mean by these two by these
two uh how am I distinguishing between
these two
I would define an analytical false
positive meaning that you're detecting
reactivity in your assay even though the
patient does not have an antigen
specific Auto antibody the direct that
is recognized in that specific antigen
so that to me is an analytical false
positive in comparison to a clinical
false positive which means that the
patient actually has an autoantibody
against that antigen that you are
detecting it's just that they don't have
clinically apparent disease at this
point in time
what could cause an analytical false
positive it's difficult to say maybe
there's some non-specific binding maybe
there's reactivity to a contaminating
antigen that's present within the assay
but basically you're there's something
that is giving you reactivity that you
are detecting even though the patient
doesn't have the auto antibody of
Interest
whereas a clinical false positive the
patient has that autoantibody this could
be results from an autoimmune process
that's happening they may be early on in
their disease process but it it doesn't
it doesn't take away from the fact that
they actually have that autoantibody and
so from an analytical perspective it's
not a false positive right they actually
have the auto antibody they just don't
have clinically apparent disease that
goes along with it at this point in in
time
so when we come back to our CCP
comparison here then how do we start to
distinguish and how do we start to
understand the nature of these
discrepancies are we are we looking at
analytical false positives do we have
clinical false positives and when we
when we did this testing and we started
to when we did this method comparison we
actually did also have diagnostic
information available from these
individuals we ended up when we when we
did chart review on these patients we
had 98 individuals who had a clinical
diagnosis of rheumatoid arthritis we had
77 individuals who had another
connective tissue disease that was
diagnosed and we had 100 healthy
controls that we included
so when we use that information to
calculate sensitivity and specificity
clinically we find that gen that we had
almost identical sensitivity between the
two methods that we were looking at but
the specificity of assay number one was
slightly reduced in comparison to essay
number two
leading us to believe or what we were
able to when we looked at the clinical
diagnosis is that at least some of these
positive results that were generated on
assay number one the patient did not
have a diagnosis of rheumatoid arthritis
now does that necessarily prove that
these are false positive results or at
least analytical false positives I I
would say no because the patient these
individuals still may have the
autoantibody it's just that they don't
have clinically apparent rheumatoid
arthritis they haven't been diagnosed at
this particular Point yet
so even when you have clinical
information I think distinguishing
between an analytical false positive or
clinical false positive positive can
still be challenging however
knowing how the sensitivity specificity
Compares against across these two
different methods in conjunction with
our method comparison I think provides a
lot of useful information on the
performance of these of these two
different assays
now I'm going to show you a different
example where we took a different
approach for demonstration of accuracy
and this is for the anti-phosphatidyl
Syrian prothrombin IGG testing now this
is a a non-criteria
non-criteria autoantibody that has been
associated with antiphospholipid
syndrome and in particular literature
reports has suggested that the presence
of an anti-phosphatidylserine
prothrombin IGG correlated with the
presence of a functional Lupus
anticoagulant
so we collected paired serum samples
from samples that had been tested for
Lupus anticoagulant we ended up with a
total of 69 samples there were 13
samples where the Lupus anticoagulant
testing was positive and the remaining
56 were negative we then measured the
phosphatidylserine prothrombin IGG and
the paired serum and then looked at
qualitative concordance with the
functional Lupus anticoagulant testing
and this is what we this is what we
observed again
we had an overall concordance of about
81.5 percent which are shown here with
these samples however we had a fair
number of discrepancy samples there were
six samples and they were discrepant in
both directions meaning that we had six
samples which were positive or showed
the presence of a functional Lupus
anticoagulant where the pspt was
negative on the other hand we had
several samples which were positive for
prostatyl serine prothrombin which were
negative for a functional Lupus
anticoagulant now I will say that we did
try to investigate these discrepancies
but it became very difficult number one
it's difficult because the Lupus
anticoagulant testing there are a lot of
subtleties to that
and we were relying on the the
um coagulation Specialists to to help us
make these interpretations on the
lupusana coagulate whether overall they
thought there was enough evidence to
support the presence of dysfunctional
testing
um but in some cases the the
um abnormalities that they were seeing
on the functional lupus and that
coagulant were fairly minimal and that
could explain some of these
discrepancies possibly on the other hand
some of these samples where the pspt IGG
was positive with the Lupus
anticoagulant was negative this may
actually reflect the presence of some
kind of inhibitor such as Heparin and
that may explain why we see some of
these discrepancies as well
but the point here is that again you
know we were we were trying to assess
accuracy of our of our IGG
phosphatidylserine prothrombin by
comparing it to a related
um test
um and sometimes this you know can be it
can be useful information but it also
can be sometimes difficult to uh
understand when you when you see
discrepancies between the results
the next one I'll show you the last one
I'll show you for assessment of accuracy
we looked at um for our verification of
anti-effect and IGG testing
so most most smooth smooth muscle
antibodies when which are associated
with autoimmune hepatitis show
specificity for effect and as the
antigen so in order to assess accuracy
of our effect and assay we decided to
collect samples which had been ordered
for a smooth muscle antibody testing
which is done by indirect
immunofluorescence we then took all of
the samples and tested for the
anti-effect and IGG here's again our
description of the sample cohort we had
a total of 173 samples
um I'm sorry I have that backwards that
should have been 124 were negative for a
smooth muscle and we had 49 that were
positive for smooth muscle
and here is our correlation again we saw
um here's here are the samples where
we're seeing qualitative agreement that
gives us an overall concordance of 79.8
percent however we did have again a
significant number of discrepant results
both directions where some samples were
positive on the smooth muscle antibody
test which were showing us negative on
our effect and assay
um and several samples almost an equal
number were positive on the F act and
yet showing no reactivity on our smooth
muscle antibody testing so how do we
investigate these discrepancies well we
came back to the same approach that we
took with our when we when we had the
CCP testing which was to look at the
diagnostic performance
again we were lucky that we were able to
get clinical information on all of the
samples that we had assessed and we
looked at sensitivity and specificity of
the effect and IGG at various cutoffs
the manufacturers cut off as well as
other as well as other uh cutoffs as we
um as we were assessing what if we had
if we had a more optimal cut off to
distinguish positive versus negative and
then we looked at the smooth muscle
smooth muscle antibody using different
cutoffs again for the tighter
um
that we that we detect on the on the
indirect immunofluorescence testing and
what we observed here is that generally
speaking the effect and IGG testing seem
to give us a better combination of
sensitivity and specificity in
comparison to the SMA testing and the
reason I say that is because if we for
for example try to
normalize for specificity on the smooth
muscle testing to get a specificity of
98.7 percent we needed to use a cutoff
of 1 to 160. however that gave us pretty
low sensitivity compared to the effect
and IGG testing
um at a similar specificity of about 97
that cut off gave us a much increased
sensitivity in comparison to the SMA
so we were we were fairly confident that
the effect and testing despite those
discrepancies with the smooth muscles
testing was giving us pretty reasonable
um sensitivity and specificity from a
clinical diagnostic perspective again
that caveat that I would mention here is
that we had a limited number of
confirmed autoimmune hepatitis diagnoses
only 14 in in our entire cohort now
again does that mean that some of those
patients who maybe had a positive smooth
muscle and a negative effect and didn't
actually have Auto autoimmune hepatitis
it's possible and I think you know
further
um you know a more robust evaluation for
those clinical diagnoses would have been
necessary to to evaluate that but
um it's just again trying to show how
you might combine your analytical
comparison between methods or between
related Auto antibodies and
including clinical information
so just to summarize a little bit on on
points to consider in terms of accuracy
assessment we know that method
comparisons have limitations
that's not a really a true measure of
accuracy and you will see discrepant
results and they can be very difficult
to troubleshoot and to really understand
are you looking at false positives are
you looking at false negatives and how
do you distinguish between the two
with all that said though I actually
think that method comparisons still
provide a lot of important information
to related to how your test is
performing because knowing how your test
correlates with other methods or other
assays will be very important and in
guiding clinicians and helping them
understand results that they might see
on one method versus another
what do we say what can we say about
clinical sensitivity and specificity I
think while again this is important to
do it can be very challenging especially
when you have access to limited samples
especially when you have a diagnosis
it's relatively rare
this can be very time consuming and very
labor intensive to do chart review to
collect samples from patients with known
diagnoses
very challenging but similar to Method
comparisons if it's if it's something
you're able to do I think it does
provide a lot of valuable information
regarding how this method or how your
method is going to perform from a
clinical diagnostic perspective
so that's the end of my presentation
I'll just summarize a few points here
um we know Auto antibodies are very
heterogeneous and that can lead to a lot
of challenges for The Clinical
Laboratory
we know there are regulatory
requirements that we have to meet for
assay verification
but how we approach these for auto
antibody serology test is not always
clear
and I'll leave you with this last point
and this is something that I like to do
when I'm designing a verification design
and verification experiments for auto
antibody testing I ask myself two
questions first the first question is
how do I fulfill the regulatory
requirements this is something that we
need to be able to do but beyond that I
want to ask the question really what do
I need to know about this assay
performance in order to make sure that I
have both an analytically and clinically
robust assay and oftentimes we need to
go beyond those regulatory requirements
and in order to satisfy ourselves about
assay performance but if you ask
yourself that question I think it will
help you design really really solid
verification experiments
that will give you confidence in your
auto antibody serology testing
I'm just going to end by acknowledging
the antibody Immunology laboratory at
the Mayo Clinic
um I'm sure I showed you a lot of data
from verification experiments and I
don't have time to
um mention all of the individuals who
were involved in in the collection of
that data and assisting with those assay
verifications but I just want to
highlight that we have an amazing group
of laboratory assistants clinical lab
technologists technical Specialists
quality specialist development
technologists as well as our laboratory
supervisor and assistant supervisor who
provide an amazing support and you know
really our experts on on these
verifications and really have really
um
do a great job in in conducting these
experiments and and giving us the
confidence in our in our essays as we do
these verifications and I also wanted to
highlight my co-directors in the
Laboratories Dr Maria willrich David
Murray and antibo are um just phenomenal
resources for me and and always
available to bounce ideas off of which I
really do appreciate and I'd also like
to thank you for attending this webinar
I hope you learned something about Auto
antibody serology test verification and
I am certainly I'm happy to answer
questions either now or after the
webinar thank you thank you so much for
your time
and thank you Dr Snyder for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of this
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
so let's get started
it looks like we have
some great questions coming in from our
audience members already our first
question Dr Snyder how might a lab
troubleshoot method discrepancies that
are identified during verification
um yeah this is a good question and I
think one that anybody who does Auto
antibody testing uh will encounter at
some point uh when they're doing
verifications
and I would say there's just not a
really easy answer it so much depends on
the on the um on the specific Auto
antibody that you're you're verifying or
doing a verification for so
um probably the first thing that I would
do when I'm or when I what that I do
when I'm troubleshooting discrepancies
is to bring in the third method even a
fourth method and really get a more
global view of the nature of
discrepancies is it one method that's an
outlier is it just discrepancies across
multiple methods and you know not even
just bringing different assays in but
bringing in different methods if you
have one that you did buy an enzyme
immunoassay you know do you have access
to a method that maybe is a
chemiluminescent essay or a fluorescent
immunoassay having different methods
like that can also help to understand
when you have a method discrepancy too
you know I think it's really important
that you have a very clear understanding
of the different methods that you're
looking at what are the antigens that
are are used in those methods how are
they different from one another anything
that you can learn about that type of
aspect of the testing I think will also
help you troubleshoot and the last thing
you know that you might want to do is
think about related autoantibodies that
might correlate with the ones that
you're looking at that can also help you
understand you know when you have
discrepancies between methods in terms
of you know it is one method correlating
with a related Auto antibody versus a
different one but I'll tell you
something I really think troubleshooting
method discrepancies it takes a it takes
a bit of creativity and sometimes you
really have to think about what the best
approach is given the the nature of the
discrepancy that you're looking at as
well as the um the antigen specificity
and the different methods that you're
assessing
thank you so much Dr Snyder now our
second question coming in what are some
unique challenges associated with
verification of indirect
immunofluorescent assays
this
um I wish I had time had had time to
talk about this in my presentation
because it was something that I had
really wanted to do because I think
there are a lot of challenges
um
for
um for indirect immunofluorescence
assays one even just coming down to
Precision you know there's think there's
a lot of
um you know people people might not
agree in terms of what is considered
appropriate Precision for an indirect
immunofluorescent assay is it plus minus
one titer is it plus minus two titers
you know what do you think is
appropriate in your laboratory given the
diagnostic application of that testing
what what do you think what would you be
most comfortable with so um that's one
aspect of it the one that I think about
most frequently and maybe this is you
know largely in the context of a a
testing but it can be applicable to
other immunofluorescent assays as well
is that when you're reporting a pattern
for a given for for a given assay like
we do for a a testing where we could
report many different patterns what what
do you do during verification to assess
accuracy reproducibility of those
various patterns do you need to do
verification for all of those patterns
should they all be included as part of
your accuracy this can be challenging
because some patterns are quite rare and
can be difficult to access samples
um so but I think that you know I think
we have to think about that when we're
verifying it when we're thinking about
it in direct Amino fluorescent assay
um because we are reporting multiple
patterns and I think we need to have
confidence during our verification that
we're again accurately able to interpret
those those patterns
and then there's always the question of
when you're doing that pattern
assessment you know should you be also
assessing for correlations with the
expected standage and specific Auto
antibody if that testing is available
that could also be something that you
would include during verification so
um just kind of scratching the surface a
little bit on on really what I think are
some of the
um you know things that we might need to
think of in an additionally when we're
doing an indirect immunofluorescent
assay
thank you so much Dr Snyder and I want
to thank our audience for these great
questions coming in our next question
other than the required regulatory
components what are their parameters
should be evaluated during verification
so there are some that we also evaluate
um it does depend on the method so one
that we do fairly regularly when we're
talking about a plate-based assay
um you know 96 well played assay is we
do an experiment called plate drift so
this is you can kind of think of it as a
really expanded Precision assessment but
you're looking at it more across the
entire plate and I'll explain to you why
we have done that we have found in the
past
especially when you're looking when you
have these methods on automated pipe
cutters that if you don't have the
program set appropriately you may end up
kind of having one end of the plate
incubate longer you may have washing
that sits longer on one end of the plate
versus another just because of the
timing of the of the pipetters and what
that ends up looking like then if you do
a plate drift experiment and the way we
set up a plate drift experiment is that
you take a single sample and you run it
the entire across the plate every every
well on that plate has that has that
sample in it and what you'll see is that
on it on a good plate drift right you
should have consistent measurement
usually we say it has to be within our
intra-assay precision
you should see that across the entire
plate but occasionally when we have had
um I would say less than optimal
um less an optimal program on our
automated pipettor we'll actually find a
consistent drift across the plate maybe
either the sample kind of increases
across the plate it might decrease
across the plate it might actually
decrease from top to bottom down the
plate and that's just telling us you
know that we should be looking at our
programming because it might be that we
don't have consistent timing across the
plate and so that's something that we do
pretty regularly when we have a plate
based assay like that some other
parameters that we usually evaluate is
carryover especially if we're not having
disposable tips because you know again
we're looking at very significant
differences between positive and
negative samples and some patients can
have extraordinarily High tighter
antibodies so we need to make sure that
whenever we have a patient has a
positive that that's not then carrying
over into another another
tube or or well on our plate and so we
do assess for carryover as well and
again you can be limited sometimes with
sample availability but
it's something that I think is worth
trying with at least the highest sample
that you that you're able to get
um you know there are some others that
we can sometimes will do stability could
be one sometimes we do specificity
testing to make sure we're Tech
detecting the appropriate antigen
specificity if there are kind of related
antigens that we could have be having
crossover between so
um those are just a couple of the things
I will think about whenever we're making
verification plans for an assay above
and beyond what our regulatory
requirements would be
thank you so much Dr Snyder we have time
for a couple more questions about the
discrepancies of assays the result was
less than two neg and the other assay's
result was 177 did you perform serial
dilution for positive results and how
did you learn about which assay give the
better results
yeah so that was one of the
discrepancies I think that was on the
CCP testing um
so we did not do serial dilutions that
177 was still within the AMR of the of
the assay so we didn't feel that was
necessary so we did not do that
um and term in terms of which assay
gives the better results
um you know again this is a very
challenging
um question to answer that's why we
brought in that clinical analysis
looking at the diagnosis for the
patients
um if I remember correctly that result
the one that I'm sharing there actually
was a patient who did have rheumatoid
arthritis so at least it was that the
positive result was consistent with the
diagnosis but you know that's not that's
not always the case and again just
because the patient doesn't have the
diagnosis doesn't necessarily mean they
don't really have that auto antibody
it's certainly possible that they do so
um but those are again some of the some
of the thoughts I think we have to have
whenever we whenever we um
whenever we're looking at these types of
discrepancies
thank you so much Dr Steiner we have
time for one more question when
performing a method comparison to
validate an assay for example Elisa kit
on different platform what acceptance
criteria do you use for qualitative
results or quantitative results
yeah and this is
um so I I think this is a great question
because you're right we do look at our
results usually qualitatively and
quantitatively now qualitatively is
really the only thing we can do if we're
looking at different Eliza kits right
and I would say you know for acceptance
criteria for qualitative we're usually
in that range of 85 to 90 percent is
what we'd like to see now that does
depend too though on whether the assay
has like weak positive borderline ranges
in which case we may to simplify that
qualitative concordance we may kind of
lump them with the positive or lump them
with the negative because the more
ranges you're trying to get qualitative
agreements across the more challenging
it can be and so you know we have to be
realistic about those ranges and you
know really think about what the util
the clinical utility of those of those
kind of borderline results are anyway
and that's why we will tend to kind of
lump them with either a positive or
negative to get more of just an overall
qualitative agreement
for a quantitative
um I think the person who wrote the
question is correct the really we're
only looking quantitatively when you
have the same Eliza kit on different
platforms and I would say that you know
generally speaking we usually say that
you know if we're doing like a passing
bad block linear regression we're
looking for slopes in the between 0.8 to
1.2 range so allowing for about a 20
difference globally across the across
the methods
um and in our our Square correlation
coefficient of at least 0.9 is kind of
what our guidelines are and I think
that's reasonable looking across
different platforms again with the same
kid with the same assay
Dr Snyder I want to thank you for your
presentation today and your important
research would you like to provide any
closing remarks for our audience before
we go
well I would just like to you know again
say thanks for joining me today
um I I do auto antibody assay testing
that's my primary responsibility and so
it was really fun to put this
presentation together I hope you learned
some a little bit and hopefully we'll
take this back to the work that you do
in in your laboratory and um again thank
you for for for joining us today
well I want to thank you again Dr Snyder
for your time and I'd also like to thank
labroots and our sponsor biorad for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I want to thank our
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration and this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time take care everyone bye-bye